es ist ein super akku und schon 2022
sollen die ersten elektroautos damit
fahren können und zwar mehr als 1000
kilometer weit und weiter die daten sind
wirklich atemberaubend wenn das so kommt
ist das der game changer für die
elektroautos also was ist an dieser
meldung an klicks um science reviews
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los ging's herzlich willkommen
auch das ist zukunft und sie wird schon
2022 also in weniger als zwei jahren
realität und das passiert bei vielen
zukunftsszenarien schon weil sie werden
realität in meinem neuen buch per aufzug
in den weltraum geht es genau darum
unsere zukunft und wie sie jetzt schon
ziemlich schnell realität wird der link
ist hier unter mir denn mit vielen
gefahren chancen und möglichkeiten
werden wir schon sehr bald konfrontiert
bei der korona pandemie haben wir sie ja
jetzt erlebt aber warp antrieb
quantencomputer künstliche intelligenz
der erste kontakt zu außerirdischen das
alles könnte schon bald passieren
und jetzt wird schon bald ein absoluter
durchbruch realität und damit könnte
tesla ziemlich ins hintertreffen geraten
gerade hat ja ihren mast auf dem
batterie der inder september erklärt wie
er die konventionelle lithium ionen
batterie so aufbohren will dass sie ihn
vollkommen neue leistungsbereiche
vorträgt schon der formfaktor ist
komplett anders als der bisherige
batteriezellen stadt der größe eines
lippenstifts wird die neue batterie er
einer kleinen bierdose ende dafür wurden
das zelt design die herstellung der
zellen das notenmaterial das
kartenmaterial also die zehn und die
integration in die tesla fahrzeuge neu
durchdacht zudem an jeder stelle der
beiden folien der anode dem pluspol und
der kathode den minuspol die in der
batterie zusammengerollt sind ist
jeweils ein eigener strom ableiter
angebracht der effekt strom fließt beim
laden viel schneller in die batterie und
beim entladen aus der batterie und es
wird wegen der kurzen strecke weniger
wärme erzeugt die elektronen müssen
nicht einmal quer durch die batterie
sprich auch die gesamte elektronik kann
darauf angepasst werden das aufladen
geht jetzt in windeseile zudem ist die
cee chemie so geändert
das so gut wie keine kritischen
materialien mehr verwendet werden müssen
silikon stadt grafit mehr nickel und
kobalt das ist die neue chemie und die
batterien werden zukünftig als
stabilisator in die böden der tesla
fahrzeuge eingebaut so dass sie wie bei
den leichten oder super stabilen warben
platten in flugzeugen nicht nur die
energie speichern sondern teil der
karosserie werden aber bei all diesen
zielen die auch tester für 2022 plant
könnte der energiekonzern und autobauer
vom fraunhofer-institut überholt werden
es hat nämlich zusammen mit der
staatlichen organisation the netherlands
organisation eine absolut revolutionäre
batterie technologie entwickelt die
speciality deposition technologie kurz
halt bei ihrem herstellungsverfahren
werden ultradünne nahezu nur atom dicke
beschichtung aufgetragen
dadurch kann in den akkus viel mehr
fläche untergebracht werden die
entscheidende akku fläche ist damit
dreimal größer und auf die kommt es ja
an und nicht auf das volumen und damit
sind viel höhere kapazitäten möglich das
fraunhofer institut spricht von drei mal
mehr reichweite mit dem gleichen akku
volumen also eine verdreifachung der
kapazität bei ihren mast batterien
werden lediglich 16 prozent mehr
kapazität erreicht zudem können diese
batterien extrem schnell geladen werden
was auch bei den neuen tesla batterien
möglich sein soll für die neue batterie
wurde bereits eine firma gegründet die
salz pfeffer in eindhoven in den
niederlanden deren chef frank verhagen
spricht von 5 mal schnellere mladen er
sagt dass ein e auto entweder mit
kleineren batterien weit über 1000
kilometer oder mit größeren akku packs
in zukunft sogar über 2000 kilometer
ohne nachladen fahren kann
selbst wenn man nicht auf die
geschwindigkeit achtet und heizung oder
klimaanlage
zusätzlich laufen sollen diese batterien
nach 1000 kilometern noch 20 bis 30
prozent restreichweite haben es wäre
wirklich die revolution für e-autos und
die leidige reichweiten diskussion wäre
ein für alle mal beendet wobei man mit
texas ja heute schon ohne probleme in
den urlaub fahren kann was an dem
lückenlosen ladenetz in europa liegt für
die anderen marken sieht das eher nicht
so gut aus deswegen würde ich mich
riesig freuen wenn ihr die petition von
volker quaschning felix bellinger und
mir für ein besseres ladenetz und
stützen würde und auch verbreiten würde
also dafür einfach hier klicken
wir sind kurz vor der 5000er marke und
wollen sie noch unbedingt diesen monat
erreichen also klicken unterzeichnen und
verbreiten vielen vielen dank bis dann
bleibt dran